I was really Keen to share with number
five viewers a discovery that I made
which I was really surprised by
um I'm sure everyone out there has grown
up on these numbers the Fibonacci
numbers one one two three five eight
thirteen you know what more can there be
to say about these numbers
um they appear all over nature cut an
apple open a five-pointed star Fibonacci
number number of petals on a flower and
you know Fibonacci made them Famous by
writing about their uh occurrence in
nature but it turns out they really
shouldn't be called the Fibonacci
numbers because Fibonacci was not the
first to discover these numbers in fact
they were first discovered not by
mathematicians or scientists at all but
by musicians and Poets in India so how
did poets and musicians discover these
numbers a tablet player playing on a
drum was quite interested to make as
many complex rhythms as possible what
are the sort of rhythms you can make out
of say a long beat or a short beat
let's just take rhythm of length four
and I could do four short beats I could
go
or I could do two long beads so a long
bead is twice a short bead so it could
just go
and that fits in our kind of uh length
four but I can mix those up so I could
do short short long
short long short or long short short
now if you explore that that's all you
can do with uh kind of a length four
rhythm with long and short beats and
they turn out to be five of those if
you've counted them so five draw some
rhythms you can make with these long and
short beats so a tablet player would
like to really mix this up and might be
interested okay with a length 16 Rhythm
what how many different rhythms can I
make with long and short beats and as
they started to count the number of
different rhythms as the Rhythm gets
longer they discovered that it was these
Fibonacci numbers that counted them so
if I have a rhythm of length five you'll
find that there are eight different
rhythms I can make starting with five
short beats or or long long short the
different combinations are eight and
actually you can really see why the
Fibonacci rule remember what it is add
the two previous numbers to get the next
number in the sequence why this helps
you to generate the new rhythms because
suppose I want to generate those rhythms
of length five well I could take the
rhythms of length four and add a short
beat to those
or I could shake the rhythms of length 3
and add a long beat to those that will
be a rhythm now of length five the
number of combinations to make rhythms
of length five are the ones of length
four with the short beat on or the ones
with length three with a long beat on so
that's why adding the two previous
number of rhythms together gives you the
next one in the sequence
foreign
[Music]
by these musicians poets also interested
in uh lines of poetry with long and
short beats and so these numbers were
actually already being talked about in
India several hundred years before
Fibonacci came across them indeed
there's an Indian poet hamachandra who
talks about these numbers so frankly
they really should be called the
hamashandra numbers and not the
Fibonacci numbers at all did Fibonacci
give a nod to the Indians or not I don't
think actually Fibonacci would
necessarily been aware of the fact that
these numbers were in in Rhythm so I'm
sure he would have talked about it had
he realized that
um Fibonacci actually of course learned
about a lot of the ideas of India and
the Arabs because he spent time in
Northern Africa that's why he wrote
liberabachi he discovered these
extraordinary ideas that were bubbling
up the Arab world and he brought them to
Europe with that first book he could
have been exposed to them but I'm sure
he would have talked about that um
there's another interesting way actually
to think about
that long and short beats which is kind
of a practical challenge you can try at
home actually which is you know if
you've got a set of stairs in yours in
your house
um how many different ways are there to
climb to the top of the stairs if you
take one step or two steps at a time so
you could do each one step individually
or you could do it in two steps and
maybe you have to add another one and if
you've got an odd number of stairs but
it's the same challenge the number of
different ways to get from the bottom of
the stairs to the Top If you're either
taking one or two steps at a time is
exactly the same challenge of the long
and short week's rhythms
actually the Fibonacci numbers are
started
um from poetry and music and actually in
the Modern Age they've actually had a
kind of resurgence in poetry because
there's a new poetic form which uses the
Fibonacci numbers uh for its structure
and it's something called a fib so uh in
England where a fib is uh a lie but in
this case it's a sort of poetry and this
poet Gregory Pinkus came up with this
idea of actually why don't we use the
Fibonacci numbers to to kind of give a
structure for a poem so his idea was
each line of the poem should have the
number of syllables of that Fibonacci
number so it should start one syllable
one syllable two syllables three
syllables five eight and so on and he
felt just in the same way as Fibonacci
discovered there was a sense of growth
that connects these numbers that when
you read a poem with these Fibonacci
rhythms
um there's a kind of naturalness to it
and so here was Gregory pinkus's
um first FIB uh and you can probably
hear just kind of nice way the Fibonacci
helped build up a sort of uh a poetic
structure one small precise poetic
spiraling mixture math plus pear tree
yields the FIB
rather beautiful so I thought actually I
would offer my Twitter followers a
challenge because I thought it's kind of
a nice small type form Twitter Perfect
Place uh to to write your own fib and so
I offer this challenge out to my my
followers and I got a wonderful load of
fibs back but I've chosen my favorite
for you
um uh because I think it's it's rather
beautiful uh it's but it was by at Ben
bush
tweet tweet Marcus here's my FIB an
unwise ad-lib wait FIB on Twitter I'm
confused how many of my 140 have I used
is pretty cool and you might also know
it's 140 so it was uh pre uh the move to
280 which actually probably has the same
number of syllables I mean it still will
it might still work but I think it's
rather nice because he's gone one one
two three five eight he actually got to
13 in his FIB which is pretty impressive
after that it starts to not sound like
poetry and sounds more like uh sort of
prose so that's the way I think you've
got to stop all right Marcus can I can I
throw the same challenge to the YouTube
commenters on this video I think I'd
love to see uh uh all the the fibs that
are going to appear at the bottom of
this little uh number file video well
watched what next links to click well we
have plenty see the video description
for books by Marcus and other stuff that
you should see
[Music]
here we've seen sort of symmetry playing
the two together to generate music
[Music]
his Artistry really is being able to
write a piece of music then apply a
little bit of mathematics to it to
create something that together makes
something beautifully harmonic and
complex Professor not being a musician I
have no clue by looking at that